みなさん、ここで高低アクセントを使って、このシリーズの高低アクセント日本語
の第2話へようこそ。
私はあなたの日本語を音声で分析した
ので、あなたが日本語
を話す録音を聞いて、日本語の音声学を教える
日本人教師としての知識を活用します。
高低
アクセントと
高低アクセントピッチアクセントと発音私
はパトレオンでこれらを教えて
あなたの日本語をもう一度分析します私の
日本語は完璧にはほど遠いです、そして私
は過去にこれについて話しましたが、ええと、
私はあまりその道を行きたく
ないので みんなにとっていいと思うので
、
ビデオを
始めたばかり
な
ので、今日聴きたい最初の
高低アクセントはマデリーンなので、マドレーヌのビデオをもう一度見てみましょう。こんにちはコニチワ
[音楽]
大丈夫、マデリーンありがとう
ビデオとオーディオファンの品質は
素晴らしかった
です。一般的に、私たちは
非常に明るく、
発信的で、
その上、
あなたは確かに
あなたの日本語能力で本当に良いスタートを切っています。今
、私があなたの日本語を批評するのは少し難しいです
、そしてこれは
私が聞いていると思うことの一つが私であるからです
あなたのrの音にちょっとした問題があると思い
ますこれは私が
話すのが
難しいです私も私のrの
音に問題があるので、私がやろうとしていることは
大丈夫と言うのではなく、これは確かにあなたの
問題です
私は自分のr音の問題について話し
ますが、これについて
は過去に少し話しました
が、かなりの数の
日本人学習者がこれらの音に問題を抱えていると思います。
私がこの音について持っている音声の知識を使って、物事を分解してみてください。
日本語のr
は、ここで非常に速い音です。
もしそれが
rrはすべての
日本語の子音の中で群を抜いて最も短く、彼は
1984年のサギサカとトクラ、そして1997年のクレマツを引用しています
。
日本語のr
は
英語のrと英語のlの中間にあると
彼らは考えています。これは
、日本語のrを
鳴らす
には、最初に
舌を後ろにカールさせて
から、フリックする必要があることを意味しているに違いありません。
それを前方
に動かして歯槽堤にぶつかると、
この種の
巻き上げ運動のようになり、それから一種の
下降します
が、このトピックについて私が見たすべての証拠に基づいており、
これについてかなりの量を読みました トピック
これはこのカール運動のどれも
実際に起こらないことですそれはあなたの舌が
歯槽堤にまっすぐに行き
、それからそれを叩いてすぐ
に下がるということです
[音楽]
あなたの舌は歯槽堤にまっすぐに行き
そしてそれからそれはt
dr vanceが指摘して
いるように、これは私が本当に知りたかったポイントで
あるため、単語の最初の位置にある
ので、日本の単語が
rで始まる
場合は、先端が 舌の部分はすでに
歯槽堤に軽く載っているので、日本語
でリンゴという言葉を
言ってゆっくりと
言うと
、最初にそのrrの位置になっていると、
私の舌はすでに
歯槽堤に載っています
その
ように私が言うとき、それは音のええと動きの一部であるこの巻き上げのようなものではありません
舌はすでにそこにありますそれ
は音が
少なくともええと言葉の最初の位置で始まるところです
そしてそれは本当に良い
証拠です
それが単語の
初期位置にある場合、それはそれが正しい前に
音がないのでワインドアップが起こることを意味するので、ワインドアップはありません。
物事が
起こる
と、rの音を非常に速く言う能力が遅くなります。
これは、
レブルン博士と話し合ったときに最も重要な
ことですが、実際に
息を吐き出し、ボーカルコードを使用し
ている場合も同様です。 音
の冒頭に向かって英語のr音を出すので、
もう一度日本語でリンゴと言う
と、歯槽堤に向かって舌で始めるのではなく、
ちょうどした
ように歯槽堤に向かって音を出すのではなく、
そり舌音を
巻き上げて、
実際には日本のrの一部であるとは思わないので、このように誇張して
ゆっくりと言います。そうすると、
この
lingo lingo
lingoの
ように聞こえますが、明らかに誇張されていますが、
私が最初から吐き出し
ているように、それはすでにその種の英語の響きのrを
鳴らしているので、それは単なるストレートではなく
、日本のrlingolingoに変わる英語のrのようなものです。
あなたができることの一つは、舌
の先を歯槽堤に接触させた位置からそれぞれの音を練習
し、そこからそれぞれを言うだけな
ので、
これを見ることができるかもしれません。 でも、
それよりも速くやらなければならないかもしれません。舌の位置を速く下にフリックして、速くなるように見せようとして
いたので、少し遅すぎると言っていたのかもしれません。
日本のrの特徴の1つは
それはしばしばアドウムのように
聞こえるかもしれません
、そしてそれは接触位置
が英語と同じであるからですdそれ
は日本のdと同じではありません
そして私たちはおそらく
別のレッスンでそれについて話しますが私の耳と私の
耳に rの音に関しては完璧ではありませんが、
rの
音が
マドレーヌである
と言ったときは、私が言っていた方法を思い出したので
、私よりも上手
に言っているかもしれません。 正しい方法です
が
それ以外のこの特定のトピックをカバーしたかったことを思い出したので、ハルサンがハの歌から持っていたものと同様の問題のいくつ
かを持っていたように私には少し聞こえたと思います
前のレッスンで
、彼の高低アクセント
は、ピッチ事故の
メカニズムのようなものでしたが
、ネイティブの英語を話すルールに依存し
ていまし
た。アクセントを付ける必要のない単語
にアクセントを付ける場合がいくつかあったので、1つだと思います。
あなたが言った言葉の中で、
今年はコトシだったと
思います。前のレッスンで紹介した
言葉
とルールの1つは、ルールで
はなく、
ちょうど便利な情報の
52％
です。 日本語の3つのモーラ
名詞はすべてアクセントがないので、
高低アクセントの点でほぼフラットです。
単語
または今年は
、この
3つのビートの完璧な例の
よう
です。  ci このような状況では、
安全ではないと想定するのが安全な
場合がよくありますが、
そのような音に
は実際にはアクセントがないため、
ネイティブの英語話者としてアクセントを付けたいと想定した場合、オッズは有利になり
ます。 いろいろ
な音
でコトシ言いたいええとギメもう一度言いたいのです
高低アクセントではなく、今は
私のパトレオンを使って日本の高低アクセント
を学んでいるとおっしゃっ
ていたと思いますので
、意識しながらネイティブ入力を増やしていただき、ありがとうございます。
高低アクセントの現象と高低アクセントとは何か
、実際の知識と組み合わせた強勢アクセントとの違いは
、これらの問題の多く
が自分で解決するので、おそらくかなりグーだと思います
dマドレーヌのレコーディングを見て得られる情報
については、マドレーヌが持っていた問題ではなかったと思います。
これもまた、私が
非常に苦労していることだからです。 多く
の人が問題を抱えていると思うので、
あなたは素晴らしいスタートを切っています。
素晴らしい
レコーディングを
ありがとうございました。本当に良いです。また、パトレオンのサポートにも感謝します。
日本語を訂正したい場合は、ツイッターを使用しながら日本語
を話すビデオを送ってください。
ドガンのツイッターで
ビデオを埋め込み、ビデオへのダウンロードリンクを含めてください。
また、サブタイトルを追加できる場合は、
今すぐ行かなくちゃいけない私の子供たちはちょっと
おかしくなりますが、
すぐにまたみんなと話します